You want to share what you have to say?
I'll say what I want to say.
And if
if the consequence of that
is losing money, so be it.
That is Elon Musk in just a remarkable
stunning eye opening interview.
One of the things he said
that he didn't care
if he loses money over
inflammatory tweets that draw
the ire of Tesla's shareholders
or Twitter advertisers.
His interview made a lot of headlines
from his views on
AI to his recent attacks on George Soros
and insisting
that the mass shooter in Texas
at that outlet mall who posted
photos of large swastika
tattoos is not a white supremacist.
Watch this
and you link to somebody
who's talking about the guy
who killed
children in a mall in Allen, Texas.
And you say something
like it might be a bad psyop.
I'm not quite sure what you meant,
but but I'm saying that I thought
ascribing it to white supremacy was
there's no proof, by the
way, that he was not
There's no
I would say that there's no proof.
That is.
And that's a debate
you want to get into on Twitter.
Yes.
Because we should not be ascribing things
to white supremacy.
If if it's false,
you basically reminds me of my mate.
This is like, you know,
calm down, people.
This is not like metaphorical parallel.
You sort of you'll see.
I'm not
You said he wants to erode
the very fabric of civilization.
And Soros hates humanity.
Like when you do something like that.
Yeah, I think that's true.
That's my opinion, really.
You're going to work from home
and you're going to make everyone else
who made your car come work to the fact
work in the factory.
You're going to make
the people who make your food
that gets the limit that they can't work
from home,
that you know,
that the people
that they can fix your house.
They can't work from home, but you can.
Does that seem morally right?
I think it's very much a double
edged sword.
I think it's
there's there's a
there's a strong probability
that it will make life much better
and that we'll have an age of abundance
and there's
some chance that it goes wrong
and destroys humanity.
Hopefully that chance are small,
but it's not zero.
Let's bring in Kara Swisher.
She has covered Elon
Musk extensively
since the late nineties,
had many in-depth interviews with him.
Her podcast is on with Kara Swisher
and also Pivot.
Kara,
I just think about
your most recent interview with Elon Musk
is in a little over a year ago
at such a pivotal time.
What do you make of this one?
And those are
just some of the key snippets
we played for folks
Well, Dave did a very good job
getting a lot of news out of me,
except most of the news was nonsense,
unfortunately, especially the stuff
about the white supremacists
and calling Bellingcat,
which does a lot of interesting
investigative work.
Is it cis ops or whatever?
PSYOPS, you know,
he spewed a lot of conspiracy theories
via whatever
he he
spewed a lot of conspiracy theories.
He made a lot of pronouncements
on things,
calling, staying home morally wrong.
Although I don't feel like we should be
taking moral lessons from Elon.
But okay,
you know,
essentially the guy who makes cars
wants us to commute. Great.
Thank you for that.
I don't know.
It was just bizarre.
And, you know, and sandwiched
in between, that was,
you know, some interesting ideas.
But he seems to talk a lot now
and spew on things that he doesn't
we shouldn't
really be listening to him about.
Although Dave did a great job, as I said,
he he did do a great job. I would just.
You do you think he gets away with a lot
in terms of
just because
so many people have dubbed him a genius?
And I wouldn't
I wouldn't argue with that.
He's brilliant. But I don't know.
I just feel like people don't hold him
to the same standards
that they hold other
certainly other CEOs, too, at all.
Well, a lot of people do.
The companies involved with company
shareholders most.
So it doesn't. Yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
they like being on the gravy train
of Elon Musk and until
and until he doesn't make money for them,
until he loses money
not just for himself
and his other shareholders
don't seem to care
in the private companies,
it's not going to matter.
And of course, Tesla's
been an enormous financial success.
For those holding its stock,
although it's under a lot of
pressure right now.
He's still going to he's
still going to be tolerated
until that changes
and I don't know why it is
with this particular person,
because a lot of other people
make a lot of money for people
and don't behave like this.
But until we stop looking,
they're going to keep he's
going to keep doing this
because he likes the attention.
Well,
and care to your point
about what he said
about the Texas shooter,
which was
essentially calling it
B.S., the links to White supremacy,
even though the shooter had a swastika
tattooed on him.
The Texas Department of Public Safety
has confirmed that
they do believe
he had
these neo-Nazi ideologies
that he had at least posted about.
But you couldn't ignore
Elon Musk
talking about that,
criticizing Bellingcat,
which does great
investigative journalism.
But then his comment
in a separate part of the interview
that was unrelated, where he said,
I want to say what I want,
even if it loses me money
yeah.
He doesn't care.
Well, it's his money when he's losing it.
And in regards to Tesla,
it's shareholders money, actually.
But he that's how he feels.
And it is his money.
And he
if he wants to do that,
he can certainly do that.
He's paying a lot of money
for those views.
Of course, he's just hired
someone who's good at making money.
Linda Reno.
And she's going to spend a lot of time
pushing back his comments and,
you know,
slowly diminishing her reputation.
Unfortunately,
she has a terrific reputation
in the ad industry.
And so if you're trying to attract ads,
you know,
saying someone who's wearing obvious
Nazi tattoos is not doesn't have
white supremacist views is unusual.
I would say
and unusual for a CEO and leader.
But he seems to want to do it
and he's willing to pay the price for it.
And it's it's of course, his money
that we tolerate it.
I don't know what we can do Caitlyn.
I don't I mean, what do we
what are we going to do?
Tell him not to be so ridiculous?
I think we do that.
I think it's good journalism.
I think it's accountability.
I think it's the interview you did.
I think Dave Favre
did a really good job with that interview
because then you allow people
to see who the person is
and then they can make
their own decisions. On some level.
Yeah. Yeah, on some level.
Although some of the stuff
gets people who really believe it is,
you know, go Elon.
Say those things
about conspiracy theories.
There's a lot of arguments
to be said
that this
that this continues
to get into the bloodstream of the public
and it becomes, you know,
if he converts one person
to thinking someone not again
wearing swastikas
seems to be an indication
of white supremacist views,
in my humble opinion.
And I think most people would think
that including,
as you said, Caitlyn, the tech police
Department of Public Safety
thank you very much, Kara,
getting up early for us.
Thank you. Thank you.